Alex kurtzman still hopes that Michelle
yo will appear in his series of section
31. is the man completely deluded let's
discuss welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV movie channel not that once more with
feeling
[Music]
so in a recent interview with sfx
magazine
Alex kurtzman was asked several
questions about the future of Star Trek
now if you are a regular star Trekker
you'll know that I've talked about this
a few times and actually how Paramount
chances are I'm going to be ordering
less Star Trek in the future and there
are still several rumors going around
that actually Alex kurdsman might not be
allowed to be in charge of any future
Star Trek and they could even move to a
different production company now in this
interview Alex kurtzman was asked about
potentially a Janeway spin-off and he
basically said there are no plans for
that at the moment but there are several
plans in place he was asked about
section 31 and he said we are incredibly
excited about section 31 but I can't see
any more than that now at the moment
Michelle yo is kind of still officially
attached to that but is Alex kurtzman's
plan to bring her back to a Star Trek
series remotely sensible you have me
confused because someone else
we have spoken to a couple of people
that work in and around the industry in
Hollywood specifically for casting
agencies and basically I spoke to one
guy who said not a bloody chance in hell
Michelle yo is right now following her
amazing Oscar Victory one of the most
sought after actresses producers and
writers in Hollywood unless we really do
need to remember she is a producer and
also a writer
she is going to be able to have her pick
of projects for the next five years or
so but let's actually have a look at her
IMDb to see how busy she already is so
we'll just click on upcoming projects
for the actress Michelle yo she is going
to be in Rise of the Beast the new
Transformers movie Saw an advert for
that the other day looks terrible she's
going to play Eileen in the brother's
son that actually looks really cool she
has done a voice for the ark the
animated Mei Yin Lee she's going to be
in a film called The Haunting in Venice
she's in Avatar 3. she's in Wicked she's
in the Tiger's Apprentice she's going to
be an avatar 4. she's going to be an
avatar five
the legend of nizar is in production
currently and the gold mountain is
actually a project that she has in
development when I spoke to the guy that
I speak to about these things he said
Michelle yo is well known to be one of
the hardest working actresses in
Hollywood and it is become well known
that she thoroughly intends to utilize
and maximize the attention that she's
got from the Oscar Victory she doesn't
want to just act she wants to write she
wants to produce movies and this is
going to give her that opportunity
when I asked about Star Trek he
basically told me that is just not going
to happen
the only way Alex kurtzman is going to
get Michelle yeoh to appear in Star Trek
section 31 is if he travels back in time
12 months and actually does it when it
was first announced because then they
could have got Michelle yo to return and
she would have done
again the guy I spoke to apparently he
says it's very well known she's actually
a very loyal actress when she says she's
going to do something she does it and
she was also loved her part of Giorgio
in Star Trek so two years ago 100 she
would have returned but no chance there
it's just not gonna happen but Alex
kurtzman didn't specifically mention
Michelle yo and I did again ask around
now apparently he is genuinely still
pitching section 31 to Paramount and he
is still using Michelle Yo's name when
he says he's incredibly excited he's
incredibly excited about the
oscar-winning actress Michelle yo doing
a Star Trek series and I'm sorry he is
deluded oh enough with the Tantrum
already and if he can get Paramount to
believe even for a second that he can
actually deliver on this he's far more
likely to get them to sign on the dotted
line
but
he is selling false promises and again
speaking to a couple of people I know
Paramount know it it is not going to
happen but I actually think section 31
probably is still going to happen they
will have to rework it and they will
have to recast a main star for the
series I actually think we have evidence
of that in lower decks towards the end
of lower deck series which the Animated
Series have been really brilliant that
they do still influence the live action
series none more so than Prodigy to be
fair but in lower decks as well and
towards the end of that series of series
two they mentioned section 31 a great
deal I genuinely don't think that was by
accident and I think they are probably
in the next series of low decks and
maybe even in Prodigy going to be
mentioning section 31 a great deal more
now Paramount do not want Five Star Trek
series to be running simultaneously that
is very clear and they have made that a
very clear to Alex kurtzman they are
more than happy for the two animated
series to continue and they are very
happy for two live-action series that
will be strange new worlds and after the
final series of Discovery perhaps one
more series there is a big push though
for Terry metallis to be allowed to
continue the story of the Titan and
maybe we would see Captain seven of nine
but actually a lot of the fans would
love to see Captain Shaw with seven of
nine as the number one continuing The
Adventures of the Titan the podcast Lads
have actually got a petition up at the
moment and it's got well over ten
thousand votes to the point of recording
that they want materials to do exactly
that and I honestly think it would be
incredibly popular if they did now
season three of Picard has had some film
annoying errors in that again I've
spoken about in other videos but I don't
need to go on about now
but on the whole it's been great so far
and it also seems to be now building an
audience initially Picard season 3 could
not break into the top 10 for Paramount
on any day than after it was released
each episode was hitting around 11 12
each time
but after the fifth week it hit number
one and it looks like it's staying there
the Brilliance of season three has
really Shone through and a lot of people
are saying Terry mattalis the showrunner
for season three is the reason why and
that he should get another crack of the
whip now I honestly think at this point
however excited Alex kurtzman is about
bringing back oscar-winning Michelle yo
to the section 31 series it ain't gonna
happen
but also more importantly I really don't
think there is an audience for the
series we don't want another Star Trek
series with a very limited storyline we
want a Star Trek series aboard a
Starship that can go anywhere do
anything and have any Adventure most
people have not necessarily connected
that well to Discovery and again with
its jumping timelines
but when Star Trek does it properly they
get back aboard a Starship and they go
out and explore like Star Trek should be
we all get excited again
and if they do section 31 maybe it could
be a border Starship but the chances are
it won't be the chances are it will be
more clandestine operations and spying
and stuff
we just don't want to watch him there is
still a lot of talk about Starfleet
Academy and how maybe that could happen
they better not we don't want to watch
it
but a Titan series could work and we
would watch it
so if power mans are listening do not
listen to Alex kurtzman the man is
deluded listen to the fans listen to us
we are telling you what we want ignore
Alex kurdzman and his Dreamland
fantasies and get on with commissioning
a tightened TV series because that is
what we want
but guys give the comments and tell me
exactly what you're thinking where do
you think Star Trek should go next is
the Titan series a good idea or do you
think we could go in another direction
we're about to get a new Enterprise
why not just do that
I would love to know exactly what you
think if you are new to the Channel
please like And subscribe and hit that
Bell notification so you never miss any
of our future videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack and
you can become a patreon where most of
our new videos go before YouTube and you
can watch it without the adverts for a
small contribution each week
there's also loads of other links for
loads of other things we do with
Sidetrack in the description
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]